welcome to vlog university it's a school
for vloggers what's that you don't like
school vlog university is not a school
at all each week there'll be various
challenges or topics that i'm going to
give to you guys to inspire you to start
creating more videos a lot of people are
always like justine i don't know how to
make videos i don't know what to make
videos about in the episode directly
after i will highlight some of the best
submissions just as a side note these
challenges can take place anywhere
twitter facebook youtube daily booth the
possibilities are endless also every
week which is pretty exciting i made
some vlog university t-shirts
and i'll be giving away one of those
t-shirts to someone who leaves a comment
saying i just you know i want to vlog
university t-shirt in the comments below
then when you get your vlog university
t-shirt make sure to send me a picture
so i can add you guys to the roster of
people who have
randomly obtained a vlog university
t-shirt
your first homework assignment is to
color me a picture
you can draw a picture and color it i
also got some markers here so
i am going to color my picture
since when did crayola make their
markers black
black marker barrels let us use more
recycled plastic and curl the markers
keeping hundreds of tons of plastic out
of landfills each year
fascinating you're probably wondering
well how do i submit my homework
assignment it's pretty simple for this
week all you have to do is either add a
video response or just take a picture of
your picture that you made and post it
on this daily booth link you're probably
wondering what types of videos are you
looking for us to submit honestly it's
up to you here's a little example video
of what i would have submitted as my
homework assignment for this challenge
okay uh this looked a lot cooler in the
package
color wonder glitter i have no idea
i
don't know where all my artistic ability
went but apparently it is not in
coloring